a cold night in Gdansk and thousands of
people pay tribute to their former mayor
Pavel adamovich who'd campaigned for the
rights of migrants was murdered on stage
at this very event a year ago this
year's fundraiser here part of a
national charity drive raising money for
hospital equipment was dedicated to him
it used to be shown live on public
television
since 2017 it's only been carried by a
private channel nearly three decades but
in recent years it's become
controversial for some people here in
Poland just one example of the culture
wars being waged between liberals and
conservatives the head of one regional
councils actually refused to take part
in this year's fundraiser claiming the
event had become political this year was
supposed to be in honor to my late
husband who was murdered I asked Pavel
adamovich his widow now a center-left
member of the european parliament and
campaigner against hate speech what she
made of that maybe they are not aware
but in their selves there is a lot of
hate there is a lot of maybe
disappointment in their life and they
have bad ideas but as we see me
year by year we have a new you know
record we we gather more and more some
poles sympathetic to the ruling law and
justice party see the charity's founder
Yesha of shack as a left winger whose
politics are at odds with traditional
values it's a view shared by today is
Quyen ski who hosts a current affairs
show on public television
years of shock Washington wash his
liberal attitude is expressed in his
motto do whatever you want at the same
time he supports very problematic issues
like abortion and euthanasia which are
contrary to the current government's
vision and that struggle for control
over Poland's cultural space has now
moved here in this battlefield between
art and society oh yeah Dobbs ki cast
the Center for Contemporary Art in
Warsaw the new director here who was
appointed by Poland's Culture Minister
has spoken of the art world being
dominated by a neo Marxist ideology
saying he wants to promote artists with
other views conservative patriotic
pro-family this nomination is a
demonstration of of power because which
is known for extremely conservative
views and he doesn't have acceptance of
the art community which will make his
mission extremely difficult Poland's
political landscape is perhaps more
polarized than it's ever been with
little appetite for compromise that's
only likely to make it harder to see the
world through someone else's eyes
Nadine barber al Jazeera Warsaw